You know taking a 3 week break from youtube
coming back playing this
this is my first game playing this i think its ah
it feels good
it feels good to be back
man and i was really missing out
*GENITAL JOUSTING*
hey jack
What
Why don't you lay still there
and lemme
tickle in there
in your little hairy Irish pooper
Hey don't close your butts
Oh you close your butt when I come near you.
Jack: Yea
Pewds: Stop
Jack: You need to plug in
Oh you're right
Well I want in here.
*headphone warning*
Oh here we go
OH GOD ASVACDFCSD
I'M STUCKK!!!
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?!?!?!?
Oohh we cum in the end
OOH OOH
OH NO
What is this game about?
It goes too fast!
Am I supposed to fuck?
Or am I not supposed to fuck?
I don't..
Are you supposed to fuck Jack?
I don't get it
Green PewDiePie: Yeah you are supposed
to get in the buttholes of everyone else
-JackSepticEye 2016
Ooooh butt
augh, fuck
come on, come on
I can still do it.
Jack: WHAT?
Jack: Yeah, I don't know what's going on
Diz iz..
Diz Iz.
Hey we went full circle look at us. ;)
Pewds and Jack: *laugh*
Jack: I'm crossing my legs to explain it.
Pewds: *laugh*
Hey, hey butthole, butthole
OH HE FUCKED HIMSELF!
LOL
WHAT THE HELL?
Jack: The whole meaning is go fuck yourself
And he get the point for that?
Well you can just fuck yourself?
Then what's the point man?
-Pewds 2016
Jack: Police Officer
Pewds: I unlocked police officer
Jack: I love the police officer outfit
Pewds: So I assume that's milk.
MAN milk?
Hey I got a hula!
I got a hula hoop now!
Jack: Where do you change your outfits?
It just came to me.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
HOLY CRAP THAT EXPLOSION
Pewds: Listen you click on the...
OOHHHHHHHH ITS GRANNY!
Jack: Lemme sniff your butthole!
Pewds: *sniifs*
Pewds: Ohhh that smells *another sniff*
Jack: Go away
OHHH DAT ASS
Jack: NOHOO
Pewds: *Sniff*
Pewds: OH DAT ASS GIMME DAT ASS BOI
Hey let's
Let's get
Come on.
Come on
wtf
more wtf
Augh that sounds
the fucking sound
You know what really bothers
me about this game?
its like...
we're all the vaginas
Jack: You know what bothers me about this game?
Jack: All the penises are uncircumcised
wha- whe- where is the foreskin huh?
Jack: Where is the uncircumcised penises?
Where is my penis equality?
Why is that dude just stuck in my ass?
Pewds: I just learned Jack has an uncircumcised penis
I didn't know that
That's good to know now
Now I have Jack's penis in my brain
That's great. Thank you
Thank you for that everyone *laughs*
Alright well I'm getting forced in to this hole here...
Without any consent
I want that to be known
Alright well I'm in
Jack: BIG PENIS GET IN THE HOLE!
Pewds: This is the kind of video
where we can just upload without the gameplay
and it will just
just as interesting
What are you doing? Don't do that
I think the red one isn't replying
so we have to shove it in
we have to shove the red penis in
Green PewDiePie: That's a good point
Pewds: Come on buddy, come on
Jack: Get in!
Pewds: Get in...
Get in the hole...
Come on red penis
Get in the hole man
dafuq..
ITS TOO HARD!
We are 12
Clearly
I get it... I get it
I push you and you push in
Jack: Yea
Pewds: You got it (2x)
OH WE'RE ALMOST THERE!
Jack: Get him Felix!
Pewds: YEAH NO
Pewds: YEAAAAA (the cry of celebration and... nvm)
Alright let's play
I almost had fun in the menu
OH
Shit
OH OH OH OH
OH HE'S GOING CRAZY!
OH MY GOD
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
What the hell was that?
Pewds: Yeah come on
*Close your eyes and let you imagination run wild*
*Did you make it?*
*congrats if u did*
You know this game
really shows that video games
is...
...in fact art
Jack: Yeah
Pewds: FUCK ME FUCK ME FUCK ME!
DAMMIT
FUCK MEH
YEAHHHH *pewds has been....*
I'm sorry I have to yell that
Come on...
Come on green
There you go
ok so you get 1 point for penetration
and you get 1 point for fucking
Its just like real life!
Fuck you are winning!
Jack: Yeah when you are walking down the street
And someone presses and shut their dick in your ass
Pewds: Oh yeah
Happens all the time
No Jack
Edit out that one
Pewds: The key is to figure out who is gonna fuck ya
And who you wanna fuck
Jack: Yeah
I like how you always for me as well
Pewds: I do because
Jack: Thanks Felix
Pewds: You know what
Jack: Means a lot man.
Pewds: I think its just a natural attraction
happening here
Jack: YAY I WIN AGAIN!
Pewds: Guess I'll just fuck myself
Jack: GET AWAY GREEN PENIS!
Pewds: Hey Jack
Hey Jack...
Jack: wat?
Jack: wha- what- what do you want?
Jack: I'm shy
Pewds: I didn't know that all I could do to avoid
a penis in my ass is a clinch
y'know?
Jack: YEAH
Pewds: Make sure you clinch
Everyday kids
sorry
no.
Jack: A clinch a day keeps the dick away
-Jacksepticeye 2016(2)
Pewds: COME ON COME ON!
GIMME YOUR ASSHOLE JACK!
GIMME YOUR ASSHOLE!
YOU CAN CONTROL IT!
GIMME YOUR ASS!
YEAAAA!
AUUUUUGHHHHH
Got 'Em!
AUUUUGHH It feels good
Fuck me, Fuck me
Yesss!
NU
GIMME
AUGH FUCK ME
GET IN THERE!
WTF?
I need this Jack
I need this victory
This is really important to me
Get in
GET IN!
GET IN!!!1!!
God damn it
Get in!
Why does he don't want me? (poor pewds)
Come on butthole
There ya go! ;D
Thanks for letting me win in the penis game Jack.
I really appreciate it
Jack: OH OH
YOU DID IT!!!
Pewds: Did I?
Did I? Did I?
Pewds: OH MY GOD
I'm gonna thank my mom
I wanna thank
no nevermind
I don't want to thank anyone
Pewds: There is nothing to be said about this game
That is already said
through its amazing artwork and graphics
I hope this game wins an Oscar
For its great performance
And I want to thank you Jack for letting me...
letting me finish their appreciative
Jack: No Problem
A good friend always let his friend finish
You heard it here first
Funky Music
That #PewdArt
It's cool
Subscribe to PewDiePie
Or to Mark Zuckerberg
*brofist*
………..
……………….__
…………./´¯/‘…’/´¯¯`·¸
………./‘/…/…./……./¨¯\
……..(’(…´…´…. ¯~/‘…’)
………\……………..‘…../
……….’’…\………. _.·´
…………\…………..(